Esports can be volatile one minute
you're on top of the world and then next
you're out of a job and it doesn't
matter how big you are even the best
players in the history of Esports have
experienced it some managed to bounce
back While others disappeared for good
so today we are looking at the fall of
summit Esports greatest players but
before we get into that I need to remind
you all that we have merch head over to
shop.thescore.com and check out the
Esports collection for amazing clothing
that will make all of your friends
jealous of you alright let's get into it
here are the players that have seen the
most career Misfortune over the years
kicking off our list is the youngest
player to ever lift a major trophy in CS
go Kirby in a one-on-3 the only one
remaining there's a kit on JDM as well
it's a big kill he's gonna swing out for
the diffuser but no they can't oh my
word Kirby there are players who get
hyped up even before their first
official match but very few get to take
home the big win krb proved he was one
of the most promising young players in
the entire world when he won the Atlanta
major with astralis and he even earned
MVP honors at the event but later that
year kiarbi made the shocking decision
to join North and nobody not even his
astralis teammates understood why just
to be serious in the beginning there was
a lot of hard feelings I don't think we
wanted him to have any success with
North ultimately though leaving astralis
proved to be the biggest mistake of
kiarbi's career the Danes established a
CS go Dynasty while kiarbi won a few
dream hack events he played as a
stand-in for FaZe back in 2020 and
joined endpoint for a bit in 2022 but
nowadays Kiara Bay is teamless the
juxtaposition dude of where he was and
then leaving and then that team
skyrocketed to become the best thing
since you can slice the bread right
mentally for somebody who's so young as
he is I can't imagine how damaging that
must have been right because he took a
leap of faith on himself his decision to
leave astralis is still one of the
weirdest transfers in Esports history
in the early days of League of Legends
few junglers were more hyped than cacao
he was an absolute Beast for KT roelster
rookie very nice that goon gets that
kill really well played there Arrow just
sits there takes on zepha now he's on
the gorilla another kill kha'zix gets
out one in the resets again cacao comes
over for the Triple back then many
people considered cacao the best jungler
in the entire world he and his team won
Champion summer 2014 but they failed to
qualify for worlds that same season and
after Samsung white dominated world's
2014 the Korean Exodus began China
started importing top Korean players and
cacao joined Invictus gaming but he
never really reached the same height as
he did back home like a lot of top
Korean Talent he earned a solid paycheck
in China but didn't accomplish a whole
lot in the server and unfortunately for
cacao Invictus only became a top team
once he had already left
the lbl has never won before but that
will
the crownless are finally King cacao no
longer plays professionally but everyone
still remembers him for his iconic plays
and his infectious love
rather than a single player next up on
our list is an entire team throughout
2020 and early 2021 Sentinels valorent
roster dominated n a and even went on to
lift the game's first major
International trophy they're gonna get
the theme fuse they've done it Sentinels
are the Mosses to Reykjavik Champions
they were on top of the world to be able
to qualify already on the champion stage
getting all the points winning Masters
one winning Masters two they're on fire
so far but 2022 didn't exactly turn out
how everyone expected they didn't adapt
to the meta and their roster changes
never really worked out Sentinels bombed
out of stage one Challengers and barely
squeaked their way into the last chance
qualifier where they were knocked out by
100 thieves it is happening before our
eyes it is emphatically the end for
Sentinels dominance in North America it
is emphatically the end the team didn't
attend a single International Event in
2022 and when the org decided to rebuild
the roster at the end of the year Shazam
seemingly found out that he was out of
the picture while scrolling through
Twitter on stream looks like an article
just went out you wanna know the best
part I just found out with you guys
three years on a team and I find out
like this it was an unfortunate end of
Allen's first great roster but luckily
the players were able to land on their
feet tens and sick are still a part of
Sentinels while Shaz and Dapper joined
G2 Esports so if G2 managed to get
promoted from Ascension who knows maybe
we'll see them compete against each
other in 2024
the pistol round is arguably the most
important round in CS go it helps set up
your team's economy for the rest of the
half but a single player on B for fnatic
this is not going to be a happy setup
here Dennis is going to do the best that
he can and this man with a pistol is
absolutely insane and one player in
particular was known as the king of the
pistol round Dennis is extremely good on
these pistols to start that momentum on
fast play very fast play and there it is
Dennis On Cue on point all three kills
again
I'm done don't even buy guns just this
guy could use a USB for the entire game
and I would be convinced because G2
certainly has to be convinced it might
be there with an absolutely perfect
round Dennis was a pistol God his
performance in CS Go's most pivotal
rounds helped him win six straight lands
with fnatic back in 2016. Dennis and his
team were in such good form they looked
poised to take the MLG Columbus major
instead they fell to astralis in the
quarterfinals which unfortunately proved
to be Dennis's last big shot at a major
trophy it's annoying in a way because
when I played with fnatic I thought we
were going to win it and we were super
confident we had a good feeling we were
going to win it because we had a good
bracket and then we lost I think that
was my best chance at winning the major
since then Dennis has hopped between
various EU rosters playing alongside
some of the greatest players to ever
touch the game and although a major
trophy has eluded him Dennis is still
regarded as when fcsgo's greatest ever
pistol players
Guardian is one of the greatest offers
in CS go history The Guardian he's
trapped behind the box he gets a shot he
goes for more he's gonna hit it on
Dennis and now it's all about God you
know he gets a shot oh my he picks up
four kills and wins it Guardian won
countless titles throughout his career
but there was always one thing missing
from his trophy case despite being in
three major Grand finals he never
managed to win the big one every time
Navi looked poised to win it all they
lost when it mattered most and even when
guardian joined FaZe Clan's super team
they choked in the most tragic way
possible Match Point phase they are on
the cusp of winning this major
you saw from this position before he
cannot miss a single shot
Guardian Waits patiently as Cloud9 sets
the push up oh
all this happens they may
clown clown nine are
fayers managed to blow a 15 to 11 lead
in Boston handing North America their
first and only major Trophy and after
that things were just never the same for
Guardian his Inkay performance fell off
and even after going back to Navi things
didn't work out after jumping around
various tier 2 rosters he's now teamless
even though Guardian never got his major
he's still going to be remembered as a
goat of Cs go
so much stop baiting
the final entry on our list goes to the
victim of one of esports's most brutal
beatdowns perfect Legend was once known
as one of the best Mortal Kombat players
of all time he's a three-time Evo winner
and was one of the most respected
members of the fighting game Community I
don't think there's any doubt that
perfect Legend is the best Mortal Kombat
Predator that there is right now that is
until he tweeted this back in August
2015. PL suggested that part of the
reason Sonic Fox won a recent tournament
was because they played katana who had
recently been buffed and Sonic Fox had
none of it perfect Legend challenged
them to a first to ten exhibition match
to try and prove his point a challenge
Sonic Fox gladly accepted and it was a
massacre oh wow straight snipers off the
gate and he got the meat Advantage oh my
goodness stop it yeah once he always
getting rushed down like this usually
turns to go in harder
but Sonic Fox and macular neutral right
now
Christ little young yo chill he's your
Elder yeah no right chill
wow and the crowd is chowing wow
nobody wow okay this is definitely not a
pro PL Arena right now oh man
ladies and gentlemen I hope you guys
enjoyed the match yeah I don't think it
looked up to the hype but I think we may
have learned something here
no no we learned that sonicbox is still
better than perfect Legend that's about
all that we learned after an
embarrassing loss in front of the Philly
crowd most people in Peel's position
would pack up their things and gotten
the hell out of there the perfect Legend
wasn't ready to let it go yo please
you're making you're making Philadelphia
laugh all around me Philadelphia's dying
so please
please you should walk away now sir what
I did say perfect Legends don't speak
anymore
any words that you say
both players sat back down for one more
best of three and this 13-0 stomp
instantly became one of the biggest
memes within the fgc but for perfect
Legend it was much worse his otherwise
illustrious career was Now overshadowed
by this one exhibition match even years
later he can't escape it there's not a
day that goes by that I don't hear about
it there's not a single day unless I
turn my entire phone off and don't go on
internet and stuff I I will hear about
it see people had an affinity of of
seeing Champions like fall and fail they
like seeing the rise of a champion the
fall of the champion I just so happen to
be the one falling on that day
foreign